I used to take the kids down to Mexico
driving down to Mexico he was pumped
just pointing things out he's like is
that Mexico I'm like no that's Home
Depot uh we get to Mexico we end up
going to a restaurant you know and we
sit down and the dude drops two menus he
says to my son what can I get you to
drink young man my son's looking at the
menu and he's like
it's the way I go Jakey do not speak the
Spanish and he goes no I know how to
talk it I go
he got really cocky heels
took my order
oh we're driving up to the border border
patrol guy he says to me and I see your
ID I said yeah great he said he got a
birth certificate for the kid
I said no how do I know he's not Mexican
and I was like so I said Jacob
speak the Spanish
his head popped up from the back seat
[Music]
and the guy just looked at me and he
looked at him and he was like have a
great day
foreign